and tonight matt harvey makes his third
start and hud just trying to figure out
a way to
build on two strong innings
nikki lopez is that short
and safe at first that's what that
hustle will do here's indian shortstop
frankie lindor had one of his best games
approach wise last night the pitch and
he swings and drives one to deep right
down the line it goes gone
a two-run home run by frankie lindor
a laser down the right field line his
sixth home run of the year all
left-handed he now has an eight-game
hitting streak and he gives the indians
a two-nothing lead here's fran mio reyes
last night couple of hits drove in the
indians only run
lifted in the air deep center field back
is bubba starling he's out of room it's
out of here in front male reyes stays
red hot
his team leading eighth home run of the
year
and his 25th run batted in and it's a
three nothing indians lead as they've
homered twice in the first inning
indians with their fourth hit here's
ketchup roberto perez
in the air right field back goes solaire
he's at the wall it's gone to the
bullpen
the indians with their third home run of
the night their second two run shot
and it's now five nothing cleveland
first home run of the year for roberto
perez if you're going to throw a guy
into the fire
carlos hernandez who is not pitched
above high or rather low a ball
makes his big league debut
with two on and one out and francisco
lindor coming up
and he should get an out to center field
it's up into the gray
hernandez tags at second base but he's
not going to go anywhere as bubba gets
it back to the infield so
carlos hernandez
first big league batter francisco lindor
flies out to center field hard to
believe it's the first of september so
basically this is the stretch run
the pitch waved at and police sack has
struck out three in a row
and four overall
back to the middle
wit backhands and throws in time and a
pick by o'hearn
that's a big hang with them by the
shields
that's for sure
he thought he had a base hit wit
showing some skills at second base
now i don't know if he's said it or not
but i'll say it for him he's happier
playing second base zach blizzak back to
it bottom of the fourth inning underway
with the indians leading by a score of
five nothing here's the pitch to him
swing and a missed strike three
got him with a breaking ball and the
beat goes on for police act there's his
fifth strikeout now here's his 2-2
swing and a missed strike three went off
speed again and there is strikeout
number six for police
deep short lindor is going to bounce it
over to santana in time and ryan mcgroom
is over two and the police sack just
keeps rolling along hunter dozier the
hitter he has struck out looking and
struck out swinging
dozier cranks it to deep right field
naquin will not get this one and hunter
dozier gets the royals on the board
with home run number four
and that's his first hit of the night
dozier he put a charge into this one
fourth team fastball seeing it right out
of his hand belt high right over the
middle of the plate he waited till the
ball traveled deep towards the catcher's
glove look at that made contact
as the ball was in back of the plate
and really put a charge into it good for
him tyler
comes up with runners at second and
third and one out and now they're going
to put the tarp on the field so it
shouldn't last very long but it's coming
down pretty good right now it's a
distraction and they want to make sure
that they
keep the infield dirt as dry as possible
that's the whole point stepping back to
the plate is tyler naquin
indians have second and third with one
out trying to add to a six to one lead
infield in
and tyler drives one to left field is it
deep enough santana will tag and he will
come home and he will score and it's 7-1
cleveland the 1-2
line to center field that's going to get
down for a base hit braun mills around
third and he's going to score and the
mississippi
masher has his first rbi as an indian
now the 1-1 pitch
a swing and a shot toward right and it
is a fair ball ricochets into the right
field corner naylor hits third he's
going to try to score here's the throw
to the plate head first slide he's in
safely
and an rbi double down the right field
line by roberto perez makes it a 9-1
indians lead
rushed deep left field and ramirez has
left a yard
and that is his eighth home run of the
season
and now he's one
rbi behind rodney reyes for the team
lead he won't let frank mill take the
lead will he as soon as he does he comes
right back